اتوقعني عن الوكش تتحسن والوضع يصير
للاحسن دخل العراق في فوضى بعد حرب العام
2003 فوضى وصفها الاهالي بالموجعه سرقت
منهم الحياه والامل قبل ان تمزق البلاد
بالطائفيه التي رافقتها وبرزت التحديات
امام العراقيين من بنيه تحتيه مدمره
وانقطاع الكهرباء وندره المياه والاهم
انعدام الامن صار القتل بالشارع صار
انتشر الدمار بالشارع في العراق اصبحت
الاحزاب الشيعيه العراقيه اقوى اللاعبين
وهيمنه الاحزاب المواليه لطهران على
البرلمان وتم دمج الاف المقاتلين من قوات
الحشد الشعبي في الجيش العراقي
في عام 2011 اعلن الرئيس باراك اوباما ان
القوات الامريكيه سوف تنسحب من العراق
تاركا عددا قليلا من جنوده في بلد تاكله
الحرب الاهليه فانتهز داعش الفرصه عام
2014 واحتل نحو ثلثي مساحه المدن العراقيه
قبل ان يطردوه التحالف الدولي بقياده
امريكا
فساد طبقه السياسيه والتدخل الايراني في
شؤون العراق مع الفقر الذي انتشر بين
العراقيين دفع بالشباب الى الخروج للشوارع
في احتجاجات وصفت بغير المسبوقه ضد السلطه
اما هذا العام فقد حمل ما سماهم راقبون
بالتفاؤل بعد قول رئيس الوزراء العراقي
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي ان العراق يسعى
لتحقيق توازن في علاقاته مع الاقليم حنان
المصري العربيه